it's lemonade so I had a little Tang but  it had a lot of sugar it was so sweet  Pharrell praises Beyonce super personal  new album  is it ever dangerous to get so personal  and to put something so personal out for  the world to see like she just did she's  an artist you know I'm saying and she's  expressed herself I think it's a  beautiful piece of work and I think of  the theme the overarching theme of  forgiveness is just such a beautiful  message and we need that in the world  right now well I think what she's done  that is rare to mainstream media is she  took a singer/songwriter approach to her  lyrics the lyrics are there's no fluff  you know she gave you like a full real  installment you know and there was no  fluff there was no there's no crumbs and  it's good to the last drop this is a  really good musical emotional excursion  you know I think she did a wonderful job